surf photography tends to be shot in the
same sunny waters around the world
there's a reason one of the best-known
surfing documentaries is called endless
summer
but warm waves and blue skies are boring
to surf photographer Chris Burkard he
seeks out the frigid waters of the
northern and southern poles to make
images of Waterman writing I see swells
in places like Norway Alaska and Iceland
burkhard frames his images for maximum
impact wetsuit clad surfers paddled
through slushy waters ice-crusted rocks
and snow shrouded mountains rise in the
backgrounds of his photographs Burkhardt
has been shooting cold water surfing for
nearly a decade drawn by the utter lack
of crowds and stunning scenery on a good
day he can shoot for an hour before the
cold seeps through his thick wet suit
and his extremities begin to numb but
it's all worth it for the photographer
who finds inspiration and made the icy
extremes